DAN KOULOMZIN: Hello everybody.
Hi.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Big warm welcome to everybody
who's here in person,
and a big shout out to everyone
watching online-- hi, mom.
This is What's New
in Android Wear 2.0.
I'm Dan Koulomzin.
I'm the tech lead for
System UI on Android Wear.
BRETT LIDER: And
I'm Brett Lider.
I'm the design lead
for Android Wear.
And so for Android
Wear 2.0, we want
to redefine what it means to
be a great, useful, smartwatch.
And we want to
enable you developers
to build great experiences
for it, for users.
And so to talk about
what's new in Android Wear,
we're actually going to reflect
back a little bit on the things
that we've learned
over the last two years
since Android Wear came out.
When Android Wear
first came out,
it was very much
tethered to the phone.
And this was a great
solution two years ago
when Wi-Fi and cellular
seemed really far out for us.
But in listening to users
and listening to developers,
they have higher expectations
for a smartwatch.
They want the watch to be
able to do stuff on its own.
And so with Android
Wear 2.0, we're
introducing the concept of
untethered experiences--
where the watch can talk
to the cloud, your cloud,
over cellular and Wi-Fi.
And of course,
Bluetooth to the handset
is still great for many things.
It's about adding and
evolving the platform.
Second-- so we call
this concept standalone.
So second, Android Wear has
been about personal expression
from the beginning.
We have over 100 physical
designs that you can buy,
and we have over 4,000 watch
faces on the Play Store.
And so when it comes
to watch faces,
we really believe
that you should
be able to choose what you
want to be your watch face.
But we want more than that.
And users wanted more than that.
They want utility and
personal expression.
And so we're evolving the watch
face with Android Wear 2.0
to put glanceable
information and action
right on your watch face.
So this is the new Android
Wear 2.0 watch faces.
And Android Wear has always
been great at quick replies
about messages that are
coming your way from people
that you care about.
But we heard from
people that they
wanted a lot more than that.
They wanted conversations.
They wanted to be able
to express themselves
in a multitude of ways, and
have those conversations live on
over their watch over
the course of the day.
So we call this Messaging,
making messaging great.
And we're going to talk
about that as well.
And finally, Android
Wear launched
with Activity Tracking.
Google Fit does a great
job of keeping track
of your walking, your running,
your biking, in the background.
But we heard from people
and from developers
that they want to
do more than that.
They wanted activity
tracking with insight.
And so with this
example, this thing
that I've done this
morning, which is nervously
eat a little too much breakfast.
DAN KOULOMZIN: Whoops.
BRETT LIDER: And a fitness
app can say, well, you know,
you did that.
And you can get back on track
towards your fitness goals
by doing the following.
So this is helping users with
insight that's meaningful.
So we talk about this as
building great fitness
experiences for Android Wear.
And together, these
are Android Wear 2.0.
So we're launching
a developer preview.
We want your feedback.
And we're going to go into
detail on all of these topics.
So fitness, messaging, the
watch face, standalone apps,
and we've got a new user
interface for both the system
UI and apps, to tie
it all together.
And so to start we're going to
give a tour of that new user
interface.
And let's roll the video please.
So here I am.
I'm starting out
on my watch face.
And this is an Android
Wear 1.0-style watch face.
It's got the time, it's got the
date, but not a lot else that
helps me get through my day.
So with a simple
left-to-right swipe
on my watch face,
a sideways swipe,
I'm going to zoom out to
the watch face picker.
Any second now.
Here we go.
So just like that, I'm zoomed
out to the watch face picker.
And if I keep
sliding to the left,
I'm actually on my
next watch face.
And I've selected
Elements Analog.
The Elements Analog
is a watch face
that we built to show off the
capabilities of the new watch
face API.
So I've already customized
it with four different things
that help me.
And let's say I wanted
to change one of these.
I wanted to change this calorie
tracker over to something else.
So I'm just going to
do a sideways swipe,
tap on the gear
icon at the bottom,
and I'm editing the settings
for this watch face.
So I tap on Complications,
the left hand dial.
And Lifesum is a partner
that we've worked with--
and they help me track things
like how much water I've
drunk through the day.
So let's tap on that, and
set that as my complication.
So with a few swipes
and taps, I've
made my watch face more my own.
And it looks like I'm a little
behind on drinking water,
and I'll get to that as
soon as I get off the stage.
So that's a watch
face we've built,
but what can third parties do?
So let's check out a
third party watch face.
So again, a left sideways
swipe gets me over
to my next watch face.
And here's Ranger from Zuhanden.
And Ranger's got a
very unique aesthetic.
Zuhanden's really good at
making Ranger sing on its own.
And so we wanted to give watch
face developers the power
to style these bits of data,
that we call complications,
exactly the way they want to.
So Zuhanden's got its own color
scheme, its own type face.
And as a user, I can also
customize the watch face
to have different complications
on different watch faces
to suit different aspects of
what I need from my watch.
And Dan is going to tell
us a lot more about this.
So now let's go check out how
to add other favorite watch
faces to my watch.
So I swipe over to the right,
and I browse my watch face
drawer.
And so I just tap on
Elements Digital here,
and I've added it
to my favorites.
So cool.
I've got four
favorite watch faces.
But you know, this
1.0 style one,
this one that doesn't have
actual information on it,
I'm going to get rid of it.
So all I have to
do is toss it up.
It's gone.
So Elements is my
watch face now.
I want to cover another
important aspect
of Android Wear 2.0, which is
a basic navigational concept
of how to get the user
back to the watch face.
And so from anywhere on Android
Wear, all you have to do
is hit the hardware button
on the side of the device.
So let's say I scroll to the
bottom of my watch face figure
here, and nothing's
really resonating for me.
So I decide to go back.
I hit the hardware
button on the side,
and I'll go back to
my list of favorites.
And I hit the hardware button
on the side one more time,
and I'll be back
at the watch face.
So hardware button equals back.
And now let's check
out Quick Settings
So Quick Settings is the
place where you can quickly
get your watch to do
what you want to do,
kind of at the system level.
So all you do is drag down
from the top of the watch.
And we've made Quick
Settings a lot more compact,
and put all the actions that
you want right in one place.
And we've especially gone
deep on brightness controls.
So if you tap on the
little brightness control
here on the left, you
get up and down paddles.
And as you start
interacting with them,
we give you a live preview
of what that brightness
control is going to do to your
currently selected watch face.
It's pretty
gratifying in person.
So I hit the hardware
button to go back.
And I'll hit the hardware
button to go back again,
and I'm back on the watch face.
So let's check
out app launching.
That's something we also
wanted to make better
in Android Wear 2.0.
So from the watch face, again
I hit the hardware button
and that will open
the App Launcher.
And let's-- we'll go back
hitting the hardware button
again, and go into it again.
And you can see that
it actually comes out
from where the hardware button
is on the side of the device.
And it has this really
nice, circular reveal.
And of course, the
App Launcher itself
takes advantage of the fact
that it's on a circular watch
and it weighs itself
out accordingly.
And we've made managed to
make the App Launcher have
more icons on it.
And you can tap anywhere
to launch an app.
So here I've scrolled down
to Strava, and I can tap it,
and it zooms into Strava.
And when I'm done recording
my hike or my ride,
I can hit the hardware
button to go back,
and I'm back in the launcher.
And I hit the hardware button
to go back one more time,
and I'm back on the watch face.
And let's say I want
to launch Strava again.
So how could I do that?
I just go into the App Launcher,
and Strava's right at the top.
So we keep track of
the apps that the user
launches the most,
and put them right
at the top of the launcher.
OK.
So let's get into the bread and
butter of Android Wear, which
is notifications--
and especially
messaging from people
that you care about.
So if my watch was in
its always-on mode,
telling me the
time and showing me
the data in my
complications, let's
say I got a message
from a colleague.
What would that
experience be like?
So here's the always-on
mode, and I'm going
to get a message from Krystal.
So Krystal's message
takes over my watch face
in ambient mode
for a few seconds,
and if I don't interact
with it, it goes away.
And then later, maybe when I'm
done talking to all of you,
I would wake up the watch face.
And Krystal's avatar and the app
that she sent that message from
would come up and
visit the watch face.
And now if I scroll
up, her avatar
will reenter on top
of the notification
card for this conversation.
So yeah, let's reply
to Krystal here.
So I've got this
conversational detail view
on the notification.
If I tap on Reply,
I can do voice
reply, emoji, smart
reply-- but let's
go use the qwerty keyboard.
And with a few taps,
P and R gets me
the word I want-- "pretty."
G gets me "good."
S gets me "so."
And it's predicted "far."
And so with like
four or five taps,
I've got the sentence
I want and I'm done.
And with the new notification
API in Android Wear,
my message has been appended
to the conversation.
And Krystal's already
replied, to keep
this conversation long lived.
And Dan's going to talk
a lot more about that.
So I'll hit the hardware
button to go back.
I'm back in the card stream.
And now I can
scroll and check out
the rest of my notifications.
So here's one from Alexandra.
And then here's one
from Google Fit.
And you can see,
as I'm scrolling
I'm getting a scroll
bar on the side
with a thumb that tells me
exactly where I am in the card
stream.
Helps me orient myself.
Tells me how many
notifications I have.
So I hit the hardware
button to go back,
get taken right back
to the watch face.
And that's the tour
of the new system UI.
Let's go back to the
slides and check out
how this relates
to app patterns.
So material design
for apps is something
we're introducing
with Android Wear 2.0.
And we're really
excited what this
will do for app developers.
So with Android Wear
1.0, we had the concept
of users navigating a relatively
big two dimensional space.
Users could scroll down.
They could scroll up.
They could scroll left.
They could scroll right.
They had a lot of power.
But we found that just a
little too often, users
would get a little
confused-- where should I
go next to get more
content, to get more action?
So we've doubled down on the
concept of a vertical layout
where users start out
anchored at the top,
so they always know
exactly where to go to get
more-- it's to scroll down.
And this is reinforced, of
course, in the system UI,
where you start
on the watch face
and scroll down
for notifications.
And you start in
the App Launcher,
and you scroll down
through your apps.
So we think that
consistency from system
UI all the way through
apps will really
help users navigate Android
Wear even more quickly,
and get the most
out of your app.
So we'll look at this
in a little more detail.
We've got these classic
isomorphic drawings
that we in the Material
Design team love to make.
So your app is
mostly this content
view-- the main piece
of information or action
that your app is
responsible for.
And what you can do, if
you need to add actions
that the user needs to take,
you can add a wearable action
drawer to the bottom.
And when the user reaches the
bottom of the content view,
or changes scroll
directions, this component
can peek into view.
And if you have a more
complicated app that
has multiple views that are
necessary to render in it,
you can add a wearable
Navigation Drawer
to the top of the app
that peeks in when
the user reaches the top.
So the main benefit of this,
is that the relatively small
screen of a Wear
device is maximized
by having the content
be front and center.
And then actions are
available just off the screen,
and navigation is available
just off the screen.
So let's take a look at
this from the end user's
point of view.
So here's a user
scrolling down in an app
and they reach the
bottom and the drawer's
right there for them to grab.
And we'll loop
that around again.
So they scroll down, they
either change scroll direction
or reach the bottom,
and the drawers there.
And there's a
primary action there
that they could have tapped,
if that's what they wanted.
But if they want to
explore more actions,
they just drag that drawer up.
Let's look at the
Navigation Drawer.
And we'll wait
for this animation
to come around, one more time.
And so here's the user
at the top of their app.
And they drag down for
their Navigation Drawer,
and they can change views.
We'll watch this one
more time for clarity.
They drag down, they're in
their Navigation Drawer,
and they can change views.
So now that we've talked about
layout and functionality,
let's talk a little
bit about aesthetics.
Android Wear 1.0
apps have generally
taken their design cues from
handset-- which generally
means bright white apps.
And we think this
is great, but we
want to make something that's
really specific for wearables.
And that means that we're
recommending that all apps
develop a dark color palette.
There's two big
benefits for this.
One is that OLED
displays are actually
very powerful on
Android Wear devices,
and they're very popular.
And OLED displays consume
a lot less power when
they're set to emit less light.
So if you have less
light emitting,
you'll save the user power.
The other main benefit is
social appropriateness.
There's just a lot of contexts
where emitting a lot of light
is just not good design.
So if you're watching
a movie in the evening,
or out at a restaurant
at night, you
don't want your watch
throwing off a lot of light.
And we'll make this easy for
you, developers, to adopt.
All you have to do is tell
us your primary app color,
and we can compute
all the other shades
that you need for your app.
And this works more than like
the purple-y apps out there,
it works for all of the
apps on the rainbow.
And yeah, don't
forget the Android
Wear apps are real apps.
They have access to
the entire Android SDK.
And the Android Wear apps
are even more powerful
than the actual normal
Android apps, in that they
have always-on capabilities.
So what this means that,
if I've got visitors
from out of town that
like their Marmite,
and I go to the
store to shop for it,
and I bring that up
on my wrist and I'm
wandering the store and my
short term memory is not great,
so I just forget what
I was shopping for.
But my watch goes
into always-on mode
and it reminds me
what I'm shopping for.
It's great for to-do lists,
it's great for fitness apps.
Definitely take
advantage of always-on.
And to talk, oh yes-- to wrap
up on system UI material design,
we've got a new watch face
picker, a new app launcher,
a new notification stream,
a new navigation model,
material design
patterns for wearables.
We really want to hear what
you have to think about all
of this.
And I'm going to
turn it over to Dan
for more about standalone apps.
DAN KOULOMZIN: Thanks, Brett.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So standalone apps, as
Bret mentioned before,
we think that the
independence of the watch
is going to be really key for
experiences in Android Wear
2.0.
So that's going to let a
user slap on their watch
and go for a run.
They can count their steps.
They can track their progress.
And they can actually
stream music,
all without having to
bring their phones,
so they get faster times.
And this is also really
going to dramatically change
the developer experience
that you guys have.
And that's because
we're going to be
able to bring a more Android-y
development experience when
it comes to cloud and data,
authentication, notifications,
and distribution.
So for cloud and data,
here's how it used to work.
If the watch needed some
data from the cloud,
it would start with a
request to the phone.
And then the phone would
get the data from the cloud,
download it, put it back
in the wearable data layer,
take it over to the
watch, and then the watch
could then display it.
Well, with standalone
apps, you'll
be able to use the network
connection directly
on the watch.
So you'll be able to use HTTP,
TCP, UDP, whatever you want.
And you don't have
to worry about
whether that device has
a Wi-Fi or cellular radio
because no matter
what, we'll still
be able to, if we need to, proxy
the network from the phone.
And so you'll be able to
take all the development
patterns that you know from
Android phone and tablet
development, use all the
libraries like Volley,
and you'll maybe even be able to
reuse some code from your phone
and tablet apps
right on the watch.
And of course, you'll
still want to use
the best practices you've
learned from writing
phone and tablet apps.
And I just want to
call attention to two.
One is, don't grab data that
you're not going to use.
One mistake we see
sometimes is people
get images that are way
larger than their screen.
Well, there's no sense in
downloading data you're not
going to show the user.
So just in general, avoid that.
It'll hurt latency
and battery life.
Also, I want to talk a little
bit about Doze and Doze Light.
So those are coming
to Android Wear 2.0.
They're important
ways that we manage
the battery life of the watch.
And so you definitely want
to play nice with those.
They are responsible for
minimizing the wake ups which
are really battery impacting.
And so you can schedule
jobs using job scheduler--
this is our
recommended practice.
You'll be able to schedule
those jobs on the basis of time,
whether or not you need a
connection to the internet,
or whether or not you need
power for long running
tasks or things like that.
And so this is
really great already
for things like downloading
the weather from the cloud,
and showing that to users.
But if you're wanting to do more
maybe privacy sensitive things,
maybe a messaging
application, then you
want to worry about
authentication.
And so with Android Wear
2.0 for standalone apps,
the watch will be managing
its own authentication.
We have several patterns
available that you can look at.
There's patterns
that-- all the patterns
balance developer time, user
experience, and flexibility
in terms of what platform
is running on the phone.
I'm not going to go into
all the nitty gritty.
There's tons more information
available at the Standalone
talk later today and online,
so do check that out.
So on to notifications.
So notifications
have always been
the lifeblood of Android Wear.
And the magic of
the experience comes
from them being
the same experience
in terms of the notification
between the watch
and the phone.
So if you get a
notification from an app,
it appears in both places.
If you take action on
either of those places,
it's reflected in the other.
And of course, if you
dismiss from one place,
it's gone from
the other as well.
And that has been achieved
in the past with notification
bridging.
And that's still definitely
an option for you.
But now that you've
got the network,
you may want to manage
notifications directly
from your standalone app.
So you can, by the way, use
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
formally known as GCM,
Google Cloud Messaging,
to actually have the
server wake up your watch
and then the watch
can notify the user.
So now that you're able to
generate notifications directly
from the watch, you may want to
shut off notification bridging.
And there's an API for that.
And also we have some
patterns on helping
to keep that replicated
experience so that interactions
seem to happen in both places.
So now onto distribution.
So this is a big change
in Android Wear 2.0.
It used to be that to
ship watch software,
you would embed it
in your phone APK.
And it's been unnecessary
stuff for users to download.
And it, of course,
affects disk space.
And now in Android
Wear 2.0, watches
can download and install apps
directly from the Play Store.
And not only does this fix the
problem of growing phone APKs,
but it also makes it
possible to ship apps
to watches without
having to worry
about what operating system is
running on the paired phone.
So you'll be able to
reach a lot more users.
And so yeah, it's great news.
[APPLAUSE]
So standalone is a
really big change.
Not only does it let users
interact with their devices
in more ways, but it's also
a huge change for developers.
So now you can just do so
much more on the watch itself,
and we're really excited to
see what happens now with you
guys taking advantage of this.
All right, on to watch faces.
Now watch faces have always
been a really key part
of Android Wear.
From the very start, we
had always-on watch faces
so the watch is always
ready to tell you the time.
And you developers really
ran with our watch face APIs,
and now there are
thousands of watch
faces available
on the Play Store.
They let users
really customize how
their watches look-- super
important, considering
this is something we wear.
And then the interactivity APIs
that we added last year really
made the watch face a tool.
So it's not just
for showing data,
it's for interaction as well.
And so we wanted to
take that and bring it
to all of the apps that
run on Android Wear.
So imagine if all of the apps
could participate on the watch
face, show information,
and then generate
those user experiences.
So we're adding this
complications API
in Android Wear 2.0.
So the term
"complications" comes
from traditional
watchmaking, and it
refers to any
informative element
on the watch face that's not
just telling you the time.
So on traditional
watch faces, this
can tell you the
day of the week,
or the day of the month, when
your alarm's going to go off,
or maybe the phases of the moon.
BRETT LIDER: Phases of the moon.
Super important to have that.
DAN KOULOMZIN: Yeah.
If you're a werewolf
hunter, very important.
And we think for
smartwatches, they
should be able to do
smartwatch-y things,
these complications.
So they should tell you
smartwatch type of data,
like how many
steps you've taken,
how many calories
maybe you've eaten,
if you have incoming messages.
And of course, they should
also react to touch.
So touching that
notification should drive me
to an experience where
I can then act on it.
And so the complications API
is an API for data providers
and watch face developers.
And it lets the
two work together
to provide both form and
function to the watch face.
And there's no need for them to
know anything about each other
in advance-- no biz dev
deals to sign for data,
or anything like that.
So for data providers,
this is a big deal.
It's going to let you get your
interactions, and your data,
on a lot more watch faces.
In fact, you'll be able
to have your data rendered
by top fashion brands
and other experts
making beautiful watch faces.
And of course, you can drive
users back to your applications
by when they touch the
complications because you
assign a pending intent that
gets sent when they do that.
So Lifesum has been able to
add some complications to watch
faces that can do things like
track Brett's drinks of water,
let him know how he's
doing with his goals.
And you get back to
Lifesum to blob all that.
And watch face
developers are going
to be able to concentrate on
making really beautiful watch
faces, and they don't have to
acquire a ton of experience
with fitness or
messaging in order
to provide that
functionality to users.
So here's how it works.
Android Wear X is a broker,
so the two never really
talk directly to each other.
It starts when it
decides it needs
to have a complication drawn.
It sends an update request
to the data provider.
The data provider
gets that request,
it fills out this
complication data object,
and sends it back
to Android Wear.
Android Wear then forwards
it onto the watch face,
which then can draw it with
whatever aesthetic it wants,
because it owns the entire
drawing part of that.
And the way they coordinate
on the general idea
of the presentation, is
through the type that's
on that complication data.
So there's lots of different
types for lots of different use
cases.
I'm going to walk through
just a few of them.
So if you want to show the day
of the month, how many messages
you have, or maybe the
temperature outside,
you can use the short text type.
It's just a little bit of
text, and maybe an icon.
If you can go even
simpler, then maybe
you want to use the icon type.
This just shows a picture.
So, for example, it might
tell me it's sunny outside,
if I see a sun.
And of course, since these
complications receive touches,
they can also be
used as just icons
so the user knows it's like
a launcher back to your app.
And there's also a
range value type.
Think of this as a value between
a minimum and a maximum--
maybe a percentage, how many of
my daily calories I've eaten,
or how much gas is in my car.
And there's lots more examples.
You can read about them
online or you can talk to us
in the sandbox later.
And so if you're
a data provider,
you want to be thinking about
all the different kinds of data
that you have that
you can show users.
And you want to think about
what action they can take when
they touch those complications.
And if you're a
watch face developer,
you want to think about how you
can make these things really
beautiful for users.
So I want to show
you a few examples
from our partner, ustwo.
There's three examples.
In this first one, they've
taken a existing watch face,
so they already shipped,
and they've upgraded
it to use complications.
You can see they've added it
into the left and the right
there.
They found some space to their
existing face, and add them.
And it fits right in.
And I think it's pretty nice.
This next example
is a new watch face
that they've written to take
advantage of the complication
API.
And you can see that it
makes obvious reference
to mechanical watch faces.
And of course, it has
that classic-looking dial
complication.
So if you want that
classic look on your watch,
this is a great choice.
This last one takes a
lot more creative liberty
with data visualization.
It's using the background and
the color of the background--
the texture and color
of the background--
to render some data.
So if they were to hook this
up to a range value type,
then maybe as it
gets warmer outside,
the watch face gets redder.
BRETT LIDER: Our watches
were red all day yesterday.
DAN KOULOMZIN: Yeah, our watches
And I think my face may have
gotten redder in the sun too.
All right.
So Watch Faces
2.0-- it's a nice,
it's a huge change
actually, to the way
watch faces are going to
be as user experiences
and as developer experiences
on Android Wear 2.0.
I think it's really going
to unlock some great form
and function for the watch face.
All right, let's
get on to messaging.
So Android Wear has always been
a great platform for receiving
and replying to messages.
We want to make that
experience last longer
and make it more conversational.
So you could get
back to messages
as you go through your day.
So we started by looking
at what we have today,
and I just want to walk
you through what we saw.
So here I've gotten a
message from my friend Jim.
We've been chatting about
my friend Charles's new dog.
And he's asking,
what's the name?
So I'm going to swipe over.
I'm going to touch reply,
and I'll speak my reply.
The dog's name is
Brooklyn, which is
a pretty cute name for a dog.
And then I get
this nice checkmark
that tells me that the
message has been sent,
and I feel great.
And then I realize, actually,
my friend with the dog, Charles,
is looking for a dog walker.
So I'd like to actually
tell Jim, hey, maybe
this would be awesome for you.
And so I go back to the
stream and look for that card,
and it's gone.
And this is actually because
the messaging app has marked
the conversation as read
because it acted on it,
and it's withdrawn
the notification.
So now I kind of have to hassle
to get back to my friend.
So let's see what we've done
now in Android Wear 2.0.
You can see that there's
a big visual change.
And we've added-- I just
want to draw your eye
to this icon at the bottom.
That's actually an in-line
action, in this case,
it's a reply action.
And it's super easy
for users to discover.
It's right there on the card.
And when they
touch that, they're
going to get to this
new remote input UI.
As you can see, we're offering
choices now on the input method
that you pick to
talk or to respond.
And voice is still there
in case you're on the go
or don't have your
hands available.
But we also now have
touch-based input methods.
And it's an entire
input method framework.
So our creative
partner, TouchPal
has made this nice
new watch face.
And you'll be able
to make watch faces.
And when users download
and install them,
they'll be ready to go for
when users want to type.
And so now I've sent my message.
I see it appear
right in the card,
and the card doesn't go away.
And this happens
for two reasons.
The first is we're
using the new messaging
style for notifications that's
been added in Android N,
and it's also on
Android Wear 2.0.
And that's going to allow
the UI to take that reply
and just put it
right on the card.
It knows where to put it,
because of the clearly defined
semantics of the message.
And also we're asking developers
not to retract messages
until they know that the
user has dismissed them.
And we think that that's going
to create that longer running
conversational experience.
And in general,
notifications on Wear 2.0
are going to be a lot more like
they are on phones and tablets.
On a phone or a tablet,
you have this expectation
that if you swipe
down on a shade
and you touch a notification,
you get to an experience
that, for the app that
submitted the notification,
you get to a part of that
app where you can then
act on whatever you've seen.
And we want that to work
the same for Android Wear.
So we're asking developers
to set the Content
Intent to drive users
back to your carefully
crafted experiences.
Now if you're using notification
bridging, what happens?
So in this case, there
isn't an app on the watch.
But we have a solution.
So we decided to make a
great expanded notification
experience, and this works
for all notifications.
When you touch a notification,
you launch into it.
And it kind of stands
in for the app.
And for messaging,
especially, we're
able to present an
experience that's
a lot like with the best of
what we see in messaging apps.
So because of all the data
you add in your messaging
style for the notification,
we can show you
conversation history.
Your messages come
in the right place.
And we've also added
a smart replies
API that lets Android
Wear insert contextually
appropriate possible replies.
And it does that using
the machine learning
model right on the device.
And of course, as you use
your conversational apps more,
they show up on the launcher
in the recent section,
so they're easy to get back to.
And the new complications will
allow users to add shortcuts
to conversations and people they
care about right on the watch
face.
So my partner is
just one touch away.
So messaging just got a
lot more conversational.
We now have in-line
actions that are easily
discoverable and easy to use.
We have in-line replies
so messages show up right
in the right place.
We have content intents
that launch apps,
and of course,
expanded notifications
that stand in for those
apps when they're not there.
The App Launcher is
much faster to get back
to conversational apps.
And saved conversations-- you
can save your conversations
and put them right on
the watch face so you
can get back to them easily.
All right.
Back over to Brett for
hearing about the Fit
platform on Android Wear.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRETT LIDER: So as we've heard
from users and developers,
users want more from
their wearable experiences
in terms of helping them
reach their fitness goals.
And developers wanted more
out of the Fit platform
in terms of being
able to help users.
So we've heard that feedback,
and we have a bunch of stuff
to talk about in the
fitness platform.
So we're doing three things in
2016-- real-time data update
notifications, so that you can
drive contextual notifications
and experiences for users;
real-time gym activity
recognition, so that untapped
experience of being in the gym
can get a lot better with
a wearable fitness app;
and the one I'm
really excited about,
a really magical one, which
is real-time walking, running,
and bicycling recognition.
So let's talk about these.
So real-time data
update notifications
allow you to set
a pending intent
to get updates on any of these
data types in the Fit platform.
Concretely, it means
that an app like Lifesum
can look for when I've stopped a
fitness activity, like the walk
I went on this morning.
And it can say, hey, you
should have a glass of water,
based on the length
of that activity.
Or if I did a long bike
ride, it might say,
you should have two or
three glasses of water.
And call back to our
earlier experience,
if I have overeaten a little
bit, and log that in an app,
another app can look at that and
say, hey to get back on track,
maybe eat a little less or
do a little bit of a workout.
So these kind of real-time,
contextually-driven
notifications are just
a lot more possible
in Android Wear 2.0.
And we're looking forward
to what you do with them.
Second, is that we're
working on an API
for launching later
this year, that actually
recognizes the actions that
people are doing in the gym.
So that means that bicep curl,
deadlifts, push-ups, squats can
all be recognized in real time.
And then you can build
fitness experiences
around that for
people's gym time.
Third is recognizing outdoor
activities such as walking,
running, and cycling.
This means that the user,
just by wearing their wearable
and starting a run, the app that
they want to launch when they
start that activity will
just launch and support
that activity.
So for me, that's Strava.
And I can't wait to
actually use this
so that I don't have to fiddle
with my watch to launch an app
to support my run.
We're really excited
about this one.
So that's all the fitness
stuff for Android Wear 2.0.
And then just in
summary, we've made
a lot of improvements
across the entire platform--
fitness, messaging, the
watch face, standalone apps,
and a new user interface
and app patterns
to tie it all together.
But this is a developer preview.
So we want to hear from you.
So come talk to us.
Come talk to Dan and
I after the talk.
Go to g.co/wearpreview and
you can download developer
guidelines, designer
guidelines, the new emulator,
and system images for
a couple of watches,
DAN KOULOMZIN: Yeah, and this
developer preview is it's
not just about us
telling you what to do.
We also want to hear
what you need from us.
So please do, let's start
the conversation real soon.
Thank you.
BRETT LIDER: Thank
you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]